at you guys may have heard about this
big Comcast Time Warner
merger they have joined people forces
it's a basically Comcast bought Time
Warner
for 45 billion dollars that's billion
with a be and comcast is known as one
the biggest spenders in all politics
they have
over a hundred lobbyist in a in DC
and I love this so there was a big
congressional
committee on the merger and you're not
gonna believe this but
Comcast has donated money to all 18
members up that said committee the let's
look at them the donation I
Senator Durbin from Illinois 54,000 from
Comcast which is the most have any
senator on the committee
orrin Hatch got 45,000 leahy up in
vermont 52 Michael E 17
outbreak in five thousand I'll break it
also the only one to oppose the merger
and interestingly he got policemen money
can you believe that I find that hard to
believe
we've got video about friggin talking
about the major letter
I think Comcast does give money to
people who support them
nest not necessarily by their support by
I
yeah I I really don't like the role of
money in politics and i think is just
got worse
or somewhere so I think says I had was
very disturbing
a a pernicious ruling I think this
latest
cultural ruling was of all I
you know is just giving more power to
those who have
have money I
its you know funny you like that good
pernicious
heard is a funny word to Bollywood
so I just to clarify in case you weren't
listening to mister break in the guy
who's getting the least amount of money
is the only one fighting it
but he does like you know that it's not
about the money
a is ever released just that the sad
part here before we get to the murder
that the one guy who is fighting it is
getting the least but yet even he even
goes on television to say it's not that
they've been bought off
even though we know that II
I don't I i think is right and I think
we look at it too his points big money
in politics is the problem
they're going to be people who oppose
this merger at like I'm gonna make stuff
up here
viacom say they give a ton of money to
right so at some point on issues like
this you get money from both sides
so you're probably free to vote your
conscience the problem is
that whether viacom opposes it or or
Comcast bytes for nobody in there
is fighting for consumer yeah row
whether this merger happens or not it's
not like
this mergers denied not a great victory
for the american consumer
like were sort of screwed either way
which I little victory right because
then hopefully there's more competition
and pricing but anyway block there is no
there is basically should be waiting for
big debate is whether they're
for giant multimedia companies running
everything or 5.3
like it's a problem either way at let's
be honest unless you're me
five thousand dollars notta lotta mother
by so that I i think that should be
taken off the table to begin with who
gives a shit right so 5,000 so we should
get up again extra credit be
her about not having anything to do with
yeah I mean
it why would it but five thousand
dollars the 50,000 a lot because a dick
Durbin who got the most
50,000 in the course of the campaign and
all that is actually nothing too so is
that enough
to buy I echo invite that was a I mean I
presume
like I don't know who else is fighting
this but I guess the way
did some airlines fight mergers a other
airlines because it'll be great
too much competition for them I was
probably right that if i cum drips
because that they have like that
happening but I imagine the day on CBS
so
so I imagine that they don't they don't
want this and I imagine that
that the other that you know AT&T
u-verse surfer rise and file
they don't they might not like this but
everyone's too afraid to say anything
let all the huge companies that are Jack
to corporations are
totally unwilling cue but that right so
why is that
their huge companies to yeah I read that
I'm curious whether the big companies
are unwilling to fight it or certainly
the
the mom-and-pop the right to mom about
that the homotopy
billion dollar company yeah right to me
because this is the
a marriage in what the one and two
biggest gamble providers in the one and
three biggest
broadband providers but you know then
that
the content providers are the people who
Arg could also be screwed by this as
they could price specs
the app for how much they pay for each
network programs but they don't want to
fight it because they don't want to be
added
disadvantageous position I suspect that
in some sense the only people capable
playing this are other media giants like
mean great like where's box when you
need them to step headed by this like
you can't believe I'm like
I wish Rupert Murdoch would be an
automated I could be like always
rightfully going to yeah or maybe Google
could easily made a very low fiber in it
on Amazon somebody
its it matters these but but a it sounds
like
you when Al Franken is the lone voices
it sounds like you know when you have
support from orrin Hatch and dick Durbin
it's a reminder that sometimes on big
issues like this
the party's don't matter yeah what's
going on in Minnesota you know Minnesota
gave us the one independent governor
with Jessie Vetter and they've given us
Al Franken is basically an independent
product suburban what's going on up
there that you can get
a place the Kansas Michele Bachmann also
gives us these independent two words
cheese curds you I tell you they make
people act
ridiculous way yeah a unit with ice
fishing all yeah
in by air but we're watching Fargo what
the hell's going on at all far-left
I wasn't very good a lot of fun really
well i mean
well you know Michele Bachmann very
specific district taken by the way many
shows men depends what is a democrat
yeah I know he's a and Jesse Ventura
remember at some interesting fun things
but they're
he lives in mexico of the great he's all
graphite show up early next week it's
called of that good at yeah
a and what about the and I we just done
with the anti-trust
situation do we do that just not that
type thing anymore nobody cares really
reminds me money in politics we used we
talk about it here all the time for
politicians used to talk about money
about that there was something called
the mccain feingold bill
God you know like nobody got wet so I
think the wording I don't care to know
about our
William Howard Taft is attempting to
roll over is great yeah
okay so many time Warner Cable's like
going like that is that okay
don't get that with a dead body with
that fat rather
sound back to correct her into a cable
yet sure that'd
a book that it might have something to
do with former FCC Chairman who is now
comcast
senior vice president maybe that it may
be with my things can happen maybe it's
because
Comcast CEO Brian Roberts played out
over I don't know any of these things
are connected
I am to find a bar in this by
is this just going to the make it so
that we're just gonna consistently see
worsen or service
I mean that ultimately what the concern
is that our internet is just gonna keep
getting slower or it can be throttled
so that their problem that plagues if
they're not partnership with Netflix as
you think
yeah yeah I mean everybody wants the
same thing everybody wants
the most they can get for the little the
little if they have to put into it
yeah that's what the cable companies
want they want to get the most from us
what by having to do the least so and
they have way more money in
power and stuff then we have so yeah
course Irish
I'm a rise by as customer and for some
time with
files in with one other Netflix will
slow down it was sorry I watch House a
card season two and I watched it
you know when things have to put up with
your into 49 minutes or forty six on
over to be 46 minutes but it would be a
perfect
HD quality better you were getting here
right I
you're at 7:20 no idea I was dead 720 it
most consumers would be legal word
now yeah I mean geez it's like sorry for
your loss
you know yes is a yeah I mean granted
like my daughter's not hungry
right but it's like the same thing yeah
but ten fingers and toes
shit and bigger temperatures double data
rate you that yeah
it please send all your condolences to
at Batman
77 on beat where that's a big deal
really I know we gotta go but got a big
deal not
my Netflix problem but you mention when
when did just gonna start there's gonna
be most favored nation status
and and I just don't see any way that
anyone standing up to make that stop
yeah a big step for people like was born
right so by the way if you're just if
you're young turks and in general we are
on YouTube here:
so we are the type a company that could
be affected by that because the big boys
could get in bed with other online media
thing can be like oh the enteric they're
actually telling the truth
we're gonna slow down their videos so
that's why the up is on board